polar frost der alles lahm legt
eisschrank usa anfang des jahres
tagelang winter extrem und bei uns hitze
die kein ende nimmt wasser das fehlt
überall wochenlang sommer extrem zufall
nein sagen forscher zukunft diese
phänomene haben etwas mit der arktis zu
tun
dort ist es zu warm die wärme da oben
bringt das weltklima durcheinander
das ist ja nun gekoppelt an die
erwärmung der arktis
da sich die arktis in zukunft weiter
erwärmen wird ist leider davon
auszugehen dass das in der zukunft eher
schlimmer und intensiver werden
die arktisregion erwärmt sich gerade
doppelt so schnell wie der rest der welt
ist sozusagen ground zero des
klimawandels probleme praktisch überall
in der region
die permafrostböden etwa riesige flächen
seit tausenden von jahren mehrere
hundert meter tief gefroren
nun beginnen die permafrostböden von
oben her zu tauen alaska sibirien kanada
überall hat es begonnen und wird mehr in
den nächsten jahrzehnten die
aufgeweichten böden rutschen weg oder
das meer nimmt sie mit
wo die handy kamera filmt war früher
fester boden küsten siedlungen sind
bedroht und das ist noch das kleinere
übel in den permafrostböden liegen
abgestorbene pflanzen altes holz
biomasse gigatonnen kohlenstoff
wenn das passiert genau das gleiche was
zu hause bei ihnen im tiefkühlfach
passiert wenn sie den stecker ziehen das
tauf ist vergammelt und wird dabei von
mikroorganismen zersetzt dabei entstehen
wieder treibhausgase methan auch co2 das
führt zu einer weiteren erwärmung und
zum nächsten problem in der arktis gibt
es immer weniger meereis in den letzten
30 jahren hat sich die ausbreitung des
eises halbiert geht so weiter wird die
arktis im sommer in einigen jahrzehnten
eisfrei sein
sie haben dann gar kein jagdrevier mehr
keinen lebensraum ein ganzes ökosystem
steht auf dem spiel
schon jetzt wagen sich die raubtiere vom
hunger getrieben in die städte norilsk
in sibirien wird keine ausnahme bleiben
denn die meereis in der arktis verloren
geht desto besser kann die sonne das
dunkle mehr aufhalten ein teufelskreis
denn der mensch am sogenannten kipp
punkt nicht mehr aufhalten kann
dann bewegen wir uns in einem minenfeld
dann tragen wir das klimasystem in einen
zustand den wir nicht kennen das ist
unbekanntes gelände und das müssen wir
vermeiden
auch die gletscherschmelze in der arktis
kann so einen kipp punkt erreichen
das ist jetzt schon kritisch 1996 sah
der krone brien gletscher so aus dann so
und heute so zwei kilometer eismasse weg
wo das eis schnitt den boden freigibt
wie hier in grönland als die sonne den
boden das gleiche spiel mehr wärme mehr
eisverlust mehr wärme und mit jedem
dieser schmelzenden giganten steigt der
meeresspiegel die arktis markt weit weg
sein ihre erwärmung trifft uns weltweit
volker angriffs chef unserer umwelt
redaktion beschäftigt sich mit diesen
themen seit bald 30 jahren volker ich
muss sagen beim durcharbeiten des
materials zu diesem bericht ist mir
wirklich schlau geworden weil da zum
beispiel ein forscher sagt das was wir
befürchtet hatten würde 2090 passieren
mit dem klima passiert schon nächstes
jahr
das hat sich enorm beschleunigt haben
wir das alles unterschätzt das scheint
so zu sein also das tempo des
klimawandels hat eine enorme dynamik
entwickelt und das liegt daran dass es
sogenannte klimawandel turbo effekte
gibt dass ein haben wir gerade im film
gesehen das ist das auftauen der
permafrostböden da wird enorm viel
treibhausgas potenzial frei wie man das
einfangen will ist völlig offen und die
sozusagen die nebeneffekte die dadurch
resultierenden die meere erwerben sich
die meeresströmungen ändern sich die
luftströmungen jetstream all das kommt
aus dem gleichgewicht und das ist
unglaublich schwierig das einzufangen
einige sagen ist es 20 12 alles zu spät
andere sagen wenn wir jetzt richtig
loslegen dann kriegen wir gerade noch
die kurve
von wegen alles zu spät können wir uns
jetzt hinlegen haben was verbockt und es
ist nichts mehr zu ändern
so sind menschen nicht da gibt es immer
noch diejenigen die dann wirklich noch
was erreichen wollen was man jetzt
machen muss
die ganz grossen treibhausgasemittenten
ins visier nehmen das ist natürlich der
kraftwerkssektor kohleausstieg ist das
stichwort und ersatz eben durch
erneuerbare energien das ist auch der
sektor der schwerindustrie
stahlindustrie zementindustrie aluminium
da muss unbedingt was gestehen die
produktionsverfahren müssen sich ändern
deutsche stahlhersteller und das auch
angekündigt auch die deutsche
zementindustrie arbeitet dran alles viel
zu wenig das muss weltweit sehr sehr
schnell funktionieren
ist es denn realistisch darauf überhaupt
noch zu zählen das die menschheit das
technisch und politisch hinbekommt
technisch wäre es sicherlich möglich da
muss man übrigens auch technologieoffen
sein und vor einem ideologie offen das
beispiel co2 speicherung technische
speicherung gilt als hoch umstritten
muss man aber einfach mal angucken ob
das politisch gelingt das ist ja das
dilemma der vielen klimakonferenz nummer
25 haben wir ja in diesem jahr mit dem
effekt dass wir immer mehr treibhausgase
haben
man streitet sich in der regel um die
gelder wer finanziert was die
entwicklungsländer müssen da unterstützt
werden das wird ganz ganz schwierig was
man noch in den blick haben muss und das
wird auch auf der kommenden
klimakonferenz eine rolle spielen sind
die natürlichen möglichkeiten co2 zu
binden indem man zum beispiel mehr bäume
pflanzt eine studie die heute in der
schweiz heraus kaum sagt wenn man ein
drittel der bäume die es schon gibt auf
dem globus nochmal pflanzt dann hat man
eine gute chance in der tat bei 1,5 grad
erwärmung zu bleiben wiedervernässung
von mooren die binden auch ganz viel co2
das sind alles möglichkeiten aber da
muss man dran ist muss halt passieren
und in wirklichkeit passiert gerade im
brasilianischen regenwald gegen das
gegenteil die sache drängt mehr noch als
wir dachten volker dankeschön